يبدو ان للرجال سنا للياس ايضا ومكان
يعتقد انه حكرا على النساء يدخله الرجال
ايضا سن الياس يفتك بالرجال وبقوه العمر
يمضي وهذا الوباء الصامت يقتحم حياه
الرجال الذين يتجاوزون منتصف اعمارهم
التقديريه لتتغير الكثير من التفاصيل
الحياتيه بالنسبه لهم يفقد الرجال كثيرا
من هرمون التستوستيرون بنسبه كبيره في هذه
المرحله وهو ضائف الجسم تصبح اقل
ديناميكيه هذا تراجع يدفع رجال الى شباب
اقل يفقد الجسم قدرته على حرق الدهون
وتزيد التجاعيد معها يصبح رجال اكثر عرضه
للاكتئاب القصه يرويها لنا محمد خالد من
الرياض
اذا ما كنت من سن الخامسه والاربعين
واستيقظت يوما نظرت الى المراه
[موسيقى]
في سن الياس فاهلا وسهلا ومرحبا
لكن ما هو سنه الرجال يتساءلون عن هذه
المساله ويجيبوا العلم وانها حاله تؤثر
على كبار السن ممن تجاوز عمر الشباب ولها
اعراض متفاوته ترتبط بانخفاض هرمون
التجستيرون وشيخوخه
ولها العديد من العوامل ومنها انخفاض
الاندروجين في الذكور وقصور الغده
التناسليه ايضا
تشير الاحصائيات الطبيه لنا اكثر من 40
بالمئه من الرجال في العالم يعانون من هذا
المرض الصامت او ما يمكن تسميته باسمه
منتصف العمر والتي تتمحر اعراضها بين قلق
مستقبل سواء العملي او على المستوى الشخصي
الامر الذي قد يدفع للاكتئاب ولياس من
الحياه ربما تصل الى مرحله خطره اذا ما
ادرك الانسان حالته في هذه المرحله
[موسيقى]
ويبقى الامر في طبيعه الحال النسبيه بين
الرجال يعتمدوا على ما تكونوا عليه الحياه
التي يعيشها الرجل
الذي لا ياتي لمن لم يرضى ويقرع بحياته
وتفاصيلها حتى وان بلغ هذه السنه وقد قال
الناس فيما سبق لا ياسا مع الحياه ولا
حياه مع الياس والانسان الاختيار بين
الامرين بصباح عربيه محمد خالد
[موسيقى]
سالنا الناس في العراق ومصر هل تعتقد ان
الرجال يصابون ايضا باعراض سن الياس
[موسيقى]
طبعا عاده الرجال يمرون بعده مراحل يعني
مرحله المراهقه عند النساء هي مرحله واحده
بدايه العمر لكن الرجال يعني اغلبهم يمر
بمرحله مراهقه يعني متاخره
الياس بسبب انه روحهم الخضراء وكل ما كبرى
بالسن يعني تحسهم شباب عندهم المراهقه
ثلاث مراحل مرحله ال 20 ومرحله الاربعينات
والستينرات
وحب الحياه اكثر
ويحب النساء لان النساء احنا يعني نقول سر
الحياه
بالحقيقه الرجال ما يوصلون الى سن الياس
بشوف كل ما يكبر كل ما تكون روحه خضراء
وتكون علاقات نازجه
[موسيقى]
الشاب النهارده
في راجل ممكن ال ال ممكن الحاله النفسيه
تاثر عليه الشخصيه لكن في ناس لا يعني انا
الحمد لله انا وصلت ل 55 سنه و56 سنه بس
انا مبسوط ومرتاح وبابقى سعيد جدا وبسعد
نفسي بنفسي
ممكن مثلا يبقى عنده طموح اكثر في شغله
والسفر بره طبعا
في الظروف
ومع السن مع التفكير
[موسيقى]
على كل ينضم الينا الاخصائي نفسي الدكتور
محمد فريش دكتور يسعد صباحك منورنا من
جديد صباح العربيه مصطلح علمي لطال مرتبطه
بالنساء لكن يبدو انه مرض صامت يصيب
ملايين رجال حول العالم هل هذا فعلا
ماخذين الكلمه بلفظ ادبي اكثر انه الياس
ماخذين كلمه سن عمر وياس كلمه لحالها مش
ماخذينه عشان نحن لا الاجابات كانت فيها
تنوع كبير بيحكوا عن حتى البعض القى اللوم
على المراه بحدوث سن الياس عند الرجل فكان
شيء غريب همم نعم تشير الدراسات الان انه
في همم شيء علمي في الموضوع وليس مجرد وصف
خلينا نقول عام او شعبي لا في شيء يحدث
عند الرجل الفرق يمكن الجوهري بما يعني ما
يحدث بين الرجل المراه من عند المراه
بيكون واضح بشكل همم واضح جدا بمعنى انه
الواحد قصير جدا لحدوث سن عند الرجل موضوع
على فترات فبيبدا التناقص من بعد الاربعين
بنبلش نشوف انه في اختلاف في هرمون
الذكوره ونبلش نشوف في اختلاف باشياء اخرى
همم الوزن طبعا الاصابات في بعض الامراض
اللي ممكن نحكي عنها
هل جهله الاربعين هي ردت فعل على سن الياس
جهله الاربعين جهله الاربعين شو يعني هذا
مصطلح جهله الاربعين
بعمر الورد
الرجل يشعر بانه فيه ضعف في جسمه يبدا
يشعر منه فيه تراجع لا تنسى الموضوع مش بس
جسدي لانه في افكار يعني بعد الاربعين
ببلش في افكار انه شو عملت في حياتي
صحيح الاسئله
اجتماعيه ملقا على رجل هلا نعم ممكن يكون
في لينك همم ما يحدث من سن الياس جهله ال
40 واصطلاح جديد علي انا
ههه عليه الصلاه والسلام
بالنسبه للرجل يؤثر عليه شكليا ونفسيا
يعني يكون عنده قلق واكتئاب بحسب الدراسات
فقدان بعض الشعر وكذلك يمكن السمنه لكن لا
يؤثر على قدرته بالانجاب لماذا
هذا الموضوع كثير الدقيق لانه حتى القدره
على الانجاب بيصير في تاثر ولكن اذا اخذنا
من ناحيه الاداء من ناحيه راح يصير فيه
تاثر واضح جدا عند الرجل في العلاقه
العاطفيه وايضا يعني مستوى ال- افراز
الهرمونات المرتبطه بالذكوره نعم تتاثر بس
انه بيصير الموضوع همم ما زال هذا الموضوع
طبي اكثر لكن ما زال يمكن همم عند الرجل
القيام
يصيب الرجل القلق واكتئاب طبعا احنا
بنتكلم عن اعراض جسديه واعراض نفسيه على
جسدي نتكلم عن تعرق الكرش ببلش يبين همم
بشكل واضح يعني بتلاقي بصير فيه
ممكن يعني بدناش نبالغ بس انه في نسبه بس
يعني الدكتور
نفسيه والدراسات
محدوده وضئيله في ما يتعلق بسن لا الياس
للرجال فيما للنساء يعني مفصله ومشوه يعني
هل في عدم جديه في التعامل مع المسلمين
هذا تشخيص واضح بس لما نتكلم عن اكتئاب او
قلق بشكل عام وعام هون طب ما هو اي حدا
ممكن يبين عليه انه قلق وبين انه في نفس
الشيء بما يخصنا للاسئله نعم في اعراض
تصبح واضحه يعني سواء شكليه جسديه عند
الرجل او في سلوك يعني القلق الميل
للاكتئاب همم الميل همم بعض العادات
اليوميه الكسوله يعني الكسل المرتبط جدا
بسن الياس عند الرجال هلا فعليا لو جئنا
تفرجنا على كثير من الرجال بعد الاربعين
وال 45 وال 50 ممكن لا انه والله التشخيص
واضح طب واللي مش في الاربعين عندها
هالاعراض رجال الاقل هيك لا حتى انا ممكن
يصير للعلم بعض المشاكل عند الرجال بتكون
قبل الاربعين
النظام الغذائي الرياضه طبعا لما نتكلم عن
التفاؤل والصحه النفسيه يراجع نفسه يتكلم
حقيقه عن مستقبل وعن ماذا قدمت وعلاقات
الاجتماعيه
سن الياس اصعب على الرجل منه على المراه
بحكم ان الرجل يعني لا يستطيع ان يعبر عن
مشاعره بالطريقه المثلى كما نعبر نحن
ونتهم هرموناتنا
بنفسنا يعني بشكل عام الرجل يحيط الغموض
في مشاعره ويعني سواء في سن الياس او في
مشاكل الماليه او في اي مشاكل اخرى عاطفيه
في حياته فهو محاط بغموض ممكن يكون اصعب
ولكن اذا بدي احكي من ناحيه اخرى اسهل
لانه قلنا بالتدريج يعني بيحصل عنده فرصه
انه من البدايه ينتبه اذا كان في اي مشاكل
جسديه او نفسيه يقدر ينتبه ويصحح الموضوع
فعند الفرصه احسن شكرا جزيلا اخصائي نفسي
الدكتور محمد